I was a pig I would eat myself hey what
up guys it's me
Jaggi and our friend Josh and today
we're trying to find cheap verse
expensive bacon three different levels
of deliciousness and price and quality
oh I almost dropped one they called in
the experts when I was younger my
nickname was actually bacon I just
wanted to eat bacon well I do too
over here mmm bacon this one's got like
a little black bit so I'm guessing it's
probably got some sort of maple glaze
something that's even thicker so I'm
gonna say that's the most expensive
everything he said pictures yep yep I'm
with it just chilling on this meeting
there there's one of the number one
there's one the highest Alamo I am not
gonna lie though I'm probably gonna like
all of them I like this so much that I'm
there save it for later in case the
other bacon is good so far I'm holding
two that is the expensive eight and it's
like eight dollars a plate for two
slices or something that's most
expensive I think this one's Muslim to
another have no idea what brand it might
be but I do think it's the most
expensive
cheers Cheers
not as good not as good mmm I'm still
gonna eat the whole thing like what am i
eating what is this it's like I got
gristle oh my yeah
just like like I like bacon like yeah
like maybe it was done in a microwave
it's a lot thinner WAP you check the
difference guys zoom focus I know that I
said I was know like all of them but I
honestly do not like this one and that
is saying a lot
yeah okay I like the crispness adds that
little extra crunch like the fact it's a
little if we mixed our bacon together it
would be a little the middle bacon
little bacon bacon little bacon middle
bacon middle bacon little bacon middle
bacon this is definitely with least
expensive this is like barely you barely
even call that bacon I was a little
bacon right now yeah that's not good I
think this is the middle baking what a
great foreshadowing for the future look
lad has like a smooth finish on it
ooh wasn't it that crunch hmm they're so
similar it's like they're clones they
did well they do look very similar look
at this we're eating cloned bacon bacon
looks like me more like Kelly it's New
Jersey if New Jersey was completely
unlike what it looks like right ladies
oh I don't even know what to say about
it it's just this is really good this is
the bacon now I'm gonna be eating day to
day and I'm not sure there's bacon with
anything crispy but also a little soft
so we got the middle bacon
it's a lot less salty I think I was
making cannibalism is kind of looked
down upon and all of the animal kingdom
oh not humans I mean you go to jail for
it but if you get caught this one's like
middle of the road it's not bad it's
pretty good but I don't it's 15 steps
above this one yeah it's like a couple
steps below this one I still think
that's the most expensive then this one
then this one unless this is like some
like crazy organic thing yeah I think I
agree I gonna be really embarrassed if
I'm wrong but I think this one was the
most expensive middle and just one was
the cheapest cosign you know signing all
of that so which one is this one yeah
yeah
one one one four one I knew it was the
most expensive because you're really
good at knowing what bacon is and you
seems like confident on your decision
and I didn't want to be left out that's
fair if this is a cheap I'm gonna flip
this table good throw those big enough
again the cheapest the cheapest achieves
that's that's the middle price Oh oh man
so this is the cheaper step hi well that
was fine I need that brand which I still
have a little bit of you want to split
it oh cool Fatty's okay McDonald's bacon
bass McDonald's bacon big day wait what
we Donald Steffen they gave up like that
McDonald I would love if you gave me
$1,000 and a lifetime supply of
McMuffins do it do it I'm surprised this
is McDonald's bacon honestly I came in
real cocky and for that I apologize
I need to check myself you can't have
her judge a book by its cover
like if I'm like I just got that bacon
craving and I really need them
hey there's McDonald's everywhere so we
have your own paycheck you're an adult
you can do whatever you want that's
right mom oh yeah bacon for dinner mrs.
like yeah I kind of already do who do
you think you are telling Josh what to
do with his money huh thank you mrs.
Josh I hope you give me $1,000 she
definitely won't she will give me $1,000
[Music]